i don't know it's it's weird how just
adding an audience to something just
makes it incredibly more hype for me
it's it's like everything except for
sitcoms a [ __ ]
[ __ ] hate
like where's the water
i absolutely hate when sick come
remember this when sitcom went through
it like it's canned laughter phase and
it sometimes wasn't even canned laughter
sometimes there was an actual live
studio audience i'd like to argue that's
still happening is it in a lot of ways
the best one the big bang query yeah
that's not still gone going is it is
that i thought big bang theory is still
not gone i'm sure though they're still
i'm sure they're this is this dude are
they still making episodes
yeah that's what i thought
i'm sure there's still a bunch of
sitcoms we just don't know about that
have canned laughter including so
because now that's just like a staple of
sitcoms now did frasier
yeah frasier had it friends malcolm in
the middle no magma
didn't have oh really yeah yeah it
didn't have it also wait what's what i'm
thinking of
uh two and a half minutes
sorry
what's the most popular sitcoms nowadays
because you know i i i look at sitcoms
now i don't like it i never always
barely ever watch sex
brooklyn
that doesn't have candle after yeah yeah
because it's like because i i've i feel
like
it's very very popular yeah am i crazy
is it the most popular one i don't know
i'm not sure
all right most successful sitcoms
what's the most popular one most popular
yeah yeah because like i remember you
know back back in the day we'd have
things like friends
you know friends and um
like frasier and other like super mega
popular super mega popular sitcoms like
that and you know they're not to say
that it weren't funny but
i it seems like sitcoms now are going
through a phase where they've just
removed the cam laughter and i'm like
thank [ __ ] thank god for that because i
feel it was like such a rare occasion
where adding canned laughter to a sitcom
actually enhanced the comedy like in my
head i think the only two shows that i
thought were like genuinely watchable
and funny at times that had canned
laughter was probably friends and it
crowd
like other than those two shows i'm just
like
it's just it's just like it's i don't
know it's mocking where it's like please
laugh now you know it's like i actually
that's the reason i didn't like it crowd
really it was that one show everyone's
like [ __ ] this this is amazing it's so
funny it's really good i think it's
really history i think it's one of the
rare exceptions where it was like the
comedy itself was actually so funny in a
lot of episodes where i could ignore the
candle after
right you know but like there's a lot of
shows like say like big bang theory
where it's like the jokes are like
subpar at best and then it's like the
cam laughter is like laugh now
where it's like it's instructing you
when to feel emotion and i'm like no
that's not how comedy works well that's
just like the thing that i could not
stand on my camera and why i couldn't
get into the i.t crowd is because what
can laughter does is that it [ __ ]
messes up with the pacing of the comedy
or the show because people have to pause
it's literally say a joke pause for
laughter right and and you basically
subconsciously telling people okay this
is one to laugh right whereas when i see
something funny and happening in real
life you don't [ __ ] pause for
laughter when i'm not pausing every time
okay well then what about like every
like stand-up comedy show every stat
that's also a big reason why i've never
been like
you don't like stand up college i'm not
a fan of stanford oh really yeah i love
stand-up comedy yeah i'd much rather
watch stand-up special over any sitcom
to be honest
because like for one it's not candle
after it's really yeah it's real it is
real
but there's also they still do that
thing where like a lot of their jokes
are designed where they would say a
punch line and then they would pause
to leave enough space for the crowd to
hopefully laugh at the joke right and i
feel in a lot of like really good
stand-up shows i mean i'm not a [ __ ]
stand-up sp you know expert or whatever
but like i've seen enough where like
i've noticed a pattern where a lot of
the best comics they purposely make the
joke flow to the point where
that pause that they add between a punch
line and the next thing they're going to
say it enhances the computer yeah yeah
and it's like and i feel like that's no
different to how like shows like it
crowd or friends did it
where like the the joke is usually
structured around
the pause
but like there's a lot of shows like say
big bang theory it's just like it
doesn't really work because of the flow
of the conversation it just really seems
unnatural i have this weird relationship
with stand-up comedy actually because
it's it's been like this way my entire
life where you know with canned laughter
and with you know being filmed in front
of a live cd audience if i feel like
they are telling a joke my subconscious
brain just goes you are playing a you
laugh you lose challenge right now you
know
so you like the dry humor i oh well yeah
i [ __ ] love dry hair
i am british i also like dry humor but
the iot crowds are my favorites yeah
yeah yeah because yeah okay but then
here's the question have you ever gone
to see stan will call me live i haven't
no i haven't yet that's good i feel the
one where it's like the live aspect
makes it a million times i can i can i
can uh i can i can see that yeah because
when you're in an audience then you kind
of want to laugh yeah i've never asked
this are you guys musical guys do you
guys like musicals i like musicals
yeah i
enjoy i wouldn't say i'm a musical guy
i'm not like an iceberg but i like i've
seen a lot of music yeah i've never been
that guy who's like gone out of his way
to go see musicals but every time i have
i've just had like a brilliant time i
don't really like musicals
i thought you were gonna lean on being
like i love musicals let me talk about
it i don't like musicals you know what
any musicals
there's always that one because my my
hands down that's enough my hands down
favor will always be rocky horror
pictures so you're gonna ask what are
you gonna say like les miserables
that's mine
is that the only one you've watched no
i've watched uh
okay i haven't liked everything
i haven't uh i've watched that i've
watched book of mormon yeah that's a
great music great musical um
watch them on movies well that's
probably what
i hate musicals and movies as well i
sing i hate when they sing i don't want
to see i want to see a story i want to
[ __ ] hear them sing i think i think
again the only musical movie that i
really enjoy was rocky i love plays i
love watching plays
i hate watching people sing live like
like i'm not in like a concert setting
i actually like i i hate musical
in film forms you know i heard musicals
i'm so annoying but i i like musicals
when it's in stage form that's actually
the only times i've ever liked it um i
can appreciate how like how talented and
how you know how much work goes into it
yeah it's very demanding but i just
don't really like it yeah i love plays
yeah yeah i think i think i no i think i
understand your hateful like musical or
like musical numbers in too many beasts
and boobs it almost feels like it like
rips you out of the
like the flow right now i get that i
think i think that you feel that way
because for the most part the storyline
itself is like very serious and it's
told in like a cinematic yeah yeah and
then all of a sudden it like cuts to a
musical right yeah which is just like a
polar opposite but that's why i think
rocky horror was such a great movie
because that storyline does not take
itself seriously okay the entire time so
it feels less jarring when it goes into
a musical number because the non-musical
parts are just as [ __ ] ridiculous
so like but like that's another big
reason why i like i mean among many
reasons why like the cats movie [ __ ]
sucked right yeah because like for one
it looks horrible but two it's like a
serious story right that just looks
goofy yeah and so that goofiness is just
enhanced when it goes into a musical
number yeah which sucks because
if you see cats like on a live stage
it's [ __ ] amazing it's it's such a
great musical life but like which is why
i was so i mean which is one of the many
reasons why i saw the trailer to the
cats movie and i'm just like oh god why
did you do this it's so bad it's like
it's like it's like seeing the trailer
to like the worst live-action anime film
you've ever seen yeah it was really
really good it was it feels horrible
what about like films that have been
turned into musicals have you ever like
experienced that i heard that back to
the future was okay that's a back to the
future music because when we were in the
uk recently there was a back to the
future one apparently it's pretty good i
saw the death note musical
that sounds fun
no didn't write my name in the book that
was the that was very
that was i felt like i was on drugs
while i was watching that show i'm like
this is not a real thing i'm watching
because it's like
again going back to that whole like
adding musical numbers in a very serious
storyline like you can't get more
serious than a death note storyline
right and then all of a sudden like just
like
busts into this musical number of how
he's gonna kill every criminal in the
world i'm just like
i want some kills
all right i knew you were a psychopath
character but now you sound even more
like
you know what i can actually kind of see
it
yo yo you you you hear else theme you
know what the [ __ ] doo doo doo doo
doo and you you think that's that's a
[ __ ] fat b you know you yeah but like
that okay i understand if you're in a
musical setting you hear the else theme
and then it like busts into a trap beat
and then they just start dancing live on
stage but that's not what happens
theme goes so hard are you kidding me
that that [ __ ] moment where the
guitar kicks in
bro that that was made for a musical man
you know what i'm saying you know what
i'm saying yeah it's it's uh it's a
really fascinating i actually really
want to go see more like anime like
musicals just because it's
one of the most unique
entities
sells at work one as well i remember
that yeah there was a prince of tennis
one as well there was a free one uh they
did a lot they had my heroic name oh my
goroni kenshin they did one as well i
don't know why
i don't think every anime can work as a
musical you know a movie i like there's
musicals in it the original uh challenge
chocolate factory that's good that's
really good does that have musical
numbers in it i can't the gene wilder
one yeah that's what the musical number
in it has magical numbers in it like
is because the
story is so ridiculous yeah that it just
matches that world yeah yeah
it's like you know
death note you guys watched any like
traditional plays live i was actually
going to say like i tell you what this
weird rabbit hole i've fallen down in
recently
i've been watching like clips of rakugo
oh dakota's fantastic yeah yeah
rakugo is like a traditional style of
japanese storytelling it's it's stand-up
it's original stand-up comedy yeah yeah
it's it's like they're not standing up
yeah they're literally like sitting down
you take stand up right and you just
restrict basically everything so
you're not allowed to like walk around
you have to sit down in one tiny spot
and all you have as a prop is a fan and
that's it and using just that
they have to convey the story which
isn't always funny sometimes it's like
serious story
but
that's that's all you have to use to
like convey the story and there is down
comedy
this is a sit-down comedy yeah but the
reason i got into it was because i've
been i had to read like i kind of uh is
it
like a new shonen jump
so that that got me really interested to
be like okay yeah i know how they
portray in manga and everything but how
is actually looking real life and
i've never just like appreciated just
this [ __ ]
it's really is like an art form of
storytelling because we've just like
such
you see with like such
subtle changes in expressions and
mannerisms they like these racquet
performers are able to just
absorb you into this story into this
world with just like very subtle changes
in their face and just their mannerisms
and i'm like this is [ __ ] incredible
like i should not be this invested in a
story where this guy's just sitting down
with playing around with the fan
it's almost like it's weird it's almost
like because i've been to a rock ghost
show before because my grandma's really
into it um and it was really weird
because like even if you don't fully
comprehend like say the butt of the joke
or the point of the story that was that
the intention of the book yeah the bot
of the joke like you know like the the
the joke
even if you don't comprehend like the
joke or the the meaning behind the story
or whatever like it's still just
enthralling to watch especially if it's
a really good performer yeah yeah to
just sit him sit there and it's like
he's just like writing a book in front
of him yeah and you you can fully
envision everything he's saying and just
get like engrossed being like so so what
happened after that yeah it's like when
you go to like a [ __ ] family reunion
and you just have like that one uncle
who's just really good at storytelling
and it's like i might not even care half
the time about what the actual story is
but i just want to keep listening it's
kind of like that it kind of brings me
back to that zone where you're a kid and
your parents would like read you like
story time books or whatever and you're
like oh well what happens next what
happens next you know it's just
i kind of like that same feeling but
just as an adult and uh yeah i never
would have like got into if not for like
anime and manga and it was just like i'm
surprised it was that one and not raku
shinjuku that got you into it okay cause
like i i think uh i i watched raku
shinju and that's
i felt more focused on the drama aspect
yeah
where this is more like okay let's take
rakio and just shown shonen shonen if
she's shown in fire shown in fire i was
trying to make a word out of it but it's
like this this this actress who this
performer who wants to be the best
raccoon performer of all time and you
know this should they have like
power-ups
360 degrees and 0.1 seconds
basically that's how to get like i can
throw the fan up at 11 minutes i gave
takeshi hemorrhoids now he has to become
a stand-up comedian like no he has to
like slightly lift his butt up
it's like oh my god it enhanced the
story
oh my god yeah so that was like i would
love to see a raccoon performance live
because if i got that engrossed watching
a youtube video which is normally like
hey watching what live performances on
youtube then i
i would wonder what it would be like
being in that room and just hearing
hearing the performer actually do it
that's that's the kind of the same with
like kabuki or like you don't
[Music]
yeah honestly i i speak english and i
watch shakespeare and i didn't know what
was happening but i had an amazing time
yeah i i i think that
if you go to london you should watch try
and look and see if there's a
shakespeare performance i want to watch
i've never seen like a shakespeare story
live dude in the globe it's [ __ ]
awesome yeah uh unless you're standing
or a polls blocking your way
there's some seats that are sold as like
a pole that's blocking your view because
it's traditional
because it's it's literally a replica
because you just have to like kind of
[ __ ] literally yeah you literally
have to just
the whole time wow sometimes so some
traditions shouldn't be kept
so
the building is tradition so the
building burnt down right yeah they
remade it yeah one to one and yeah if
you want to stand in like the pit you
stand there like four hours of standing
below the stage looking at the stage
because that's how you get you get the
peasant experience you literally get the
you accept you're paying for it yeah
it's very cheap though
yeah yeah yeah yeah it's really really
affordable these things unless you want
the like really i thought i thought to
myself i've been in enough mosh pits
while i'm standing up for hours at a
time where i could probably do that but
like it's kind of like being in a mulch
but not moving yeah yeah
you should go it's just like this the
problem is that like they only have them
like
three four times a month and they're
always like they're always booked yeah
and it's it's never the
shakespeare story you want right i got
super lucky one time i got hamlet yeah
it's my favorite one um but every other
time i've been it's been like one of the
shakespeare ones that i i don't really
like as much
yeah i think i would only really be
interested in going to see like my
favorite one which was your favorite one
macbeth
is good
i like i like the tempest as well
uh a few other ones i like this
classic
yeah but like definitely going to that
cigarettes concert made me miss
live performances and going to see live
performances so much where like i mean
obviously worst timing to like plan my
next live show because i'm leaving five
days yeah we are the live we are the
live show we're gonna go do a live show
well technically you're getting a live
experience joey you're just uh on the
other side of the field
yeah sure i'm just like can you record
for me so i can like watch it later